foreign
you've changed your mind it seems on
coffee in so much as you now advocate
for it or at least support the idea of a
cup of coffee in the morning
and an outstanding question because we
were going back and forth on what we
should talk about in this conversation
that I really don't know the answer to
and that is why is coffee associated
with so many of the same health benefits
asleep it doesn't seem at least at face
value to to make immediate sense so so
both of those
why a cup of coffee in the morning
and why is it associated with some of
the benefits of sleep
and maybe you could also get into some
of the pharmacokinetics of of caffeine
or I mean I guess coffee could be its
own thing just in terms of Half-Life and
stuff so people have an idea
yes so I've certainly changed my my tune
on caffeine and I think just try to
change my tune in general I think when I
first came out with the book it was
just getting my
training wheels underneath me Public
Communication I think I was probably a
bit too absolutist in truth than anyone
who speaks in absolute she should always
be weary of and I was pretty much guilty
of that and I think this that was true
for caffeine and sleep in general but
let me just come back to the first part
of the question which is caffeine what
is it how does it work in terms of
waking you up how does it work in terms
of preventing you from sleeping but also
why I despite those things I would still
advocate for it all right caffeine is a
chemical as I'm sure you and everyone
else knows it's a stimulants it's a
psychoactive stimulant one of one of the
few that we feel readily comfortable
giving our children but caffeine Works
in a very interesting way within the
brain which brings us back to another
chemical that sounds very similar called
adenosine caffeine adenosine
from the moment that you and I and
everyone listening I suppose woke up
this morning a chemical built up in your
brain and that chemical is called
adenosine and the more of it that builds
up the sleepier that you feel and so we
think of adenosine as a signal of sleep
pressure it's not a mechanical pressure
by the way it doesn't mean that the end
at the end of the day your head is
nearly going to explode on the basis of
your adenosine it's just it's a chemical
pressure
caffeine Works to keep us awake by way
of competing with adenosine so the
longer that we're awake the more
adenosine is building up and that
adenosine is telling your brain okay
you're getting sleepier and sleepier and
after about 16 hours of being awake you
should feel heavily weighed down by that
adenosine signal that you can fall
asleep easily and then you can stay
asleep
caffeine works by way of racing into the
system and it latches on to those
adenosine receptors
but what it doesn't do is activate them
because you would think well if it's
binding on and latching onto those
welcome sites of adenosine in the brain
then wouldn't that make you more sleepy
well the reason it doesn't is because it
has the opposite effect well not quite
the opposite effect it races in and it
just latches itself onto those receptors
and inactivates those receptors so it
doesn't inhibit The receptors it just
blocks them and so it's almost as though
caffeine is like the mute button on your
remote TV controller it just comes in
and it mutes the signal of adenosine of
of sleepiness so it's what we call a
competitive receptor blocker and it has
very sharp elbows it will come in and it
will nudge adenosine out of the way
latch on and hijack those receptors and
block the signal of sleepiness and
that's why all of a sudden you think
well gosh I was feeling pretty sleepy
I've been awake for 14 hours I have an
espresso I don't feel sleepy anymore
it's not as though you've removed the
adenosine the adenosine is still present
sleepiness is still present and it will
continue to build up the longer that
you're awake it's simply that your brain
is no longer getting the message of
adenosine because caffeine is blocking
the signal if that makes some sense so
that's the reason that caffeine will
then
start to disrupt your sleep and it will
disrupt your sleep in probably several
different ways the first is that it will
because it's a stimulant prolong the
time it takes you to fall asleep and you
you mentioned that too the other aspect
of caffeine though is that it's what we
call anxiogenic that it increases your
anxiety
and anxiety including what we think of
as physiological anxiety biological
anxiety which is essentially having your
fight or flight branch of the nervous
system switched on into higher gear and
aspects of your stress chemistry and
things like
cortisol those things will be ramped up
by way of caffeine and that is the exact
opposite of what you need
to be able to fall asleep you need to
disengage the fight or flight branch of
the nervous system and shift over to the
more restful branch of the nervous
system that we call the parasympathetic
nervous system
and you can't do that because of the
caffeine and so what happens is that
psychologically the caffeine is
preventing you from falling asleep then
you start to get anxious because it's
anxiogenic it increases anxiety
at that point you start to ruminate this
Rolodex of anxiety begins to whirl and
you start to then
ruminate and when you ruminate you
catastrophize because everything seems
so much worse in the darkness of night
than it does in the light of day and at
that point of catastrophizing and
ruminating you're sort of dead in the
water for the next two hours as it were
stir in my life yeah I'm so sorry it's
gonna sound pain for me familiar to many
people out there
so that's one of the issues with
caffeine the other is its duration of
action you mentioned it's
pharmacokinetics
it has a half-life of what we call five
to six hours which is just a fancy way
of saying that after about five to six
hours half of the caffeine still in your
system which means that caffeine has a
quarter life of for the average adult at
least 10 to 12 hours
and I it's probably again not really a
very good analogy but you know if you
have a cup of coffee let's say at 1pm or
2 p.m in the afternoon
is it similar to then saying well that's
the equivalent of tucking myself into
bed at midnight before I switch the
light out I swing a quarter of a cup of
coffee and I I hope for a good night of
sleep it's probably not going to happen
because a quarter of the caffeine is
still in the brain swilling around
at midnight so its duration of action is
something that people may want to be
mindful of and that will impact sleep
the other component is that caffeine
will
destabilize your sleep so it makes your
sleep more fragile and as a consequence
if you are prone to waking up and we all
will wake up across the night even
healthy good sleepers will wake up
because caffeine will destabilize and
make your sleep more fragile it's more
likely that you'll wake up and when you
do wake up your sleep is less robust and
it's harder for you to fall back asleep
and so now sleep maintenance insomnia
and then the final part of caffeine
comes back to deep sleep
if we and we've done these studies where
we can dose people at different times of
the day and into the evening and if you
give people a standardized dose of
caffeine maybe 150 180 or 200 milligrams
which would be suppose the equivalent of
probably a very strongly dripped brewed
cup of coffee or probably
one and a half cups of coffee
what we can see is a decrease in the
amount of Deep non-rem Sleep
particularly in the first two hours of
the night it can decimate that that deep
sleep
in fact there was a reduction if you
look at that and we've done some of
these Studies by a single cup of coffee
in the evening it will drop the amount
of deep sleep by about 30 percent 3-0
which to put that in context I would
probably have to age you by about 12 to
14 years to get that type of reduction
in your deep sleep or you could just do
it every night with an espresso if you
wanted to and I do think that that's
relevant by the way some people will say
look I can have a cup of coffee within
or even two and I can fall asleep find a
nice day of sleep so no harm no foul
the problem there is that it discounts
the idea that you have no sense of how
much deep sleep that you get at night
yes you probably remember did you
struggle to fall asleep or did you wake
up but none of us has a recollection of
the quality of our deep slow brainwave
activity
but yet you may still be suffering from
that excising of a significant amount of
your deep sleep and so the next morning
you don't feel refreshed or restored by
your sleep but you don't remember
struggling to fall asleep or having a
hard time staying asleep and so you
discount the idea that it was the coffee
the next night but now you start
reaching for three cups of coffee the
next morning
and then so on and so forth the sort of
vicious cycle Begins the harder it is
the next night to fall asleep the less
deep sleep the more coffee you get and
then people start falling into the Trap
of alcohol or sleeping aids so so let me
hop in let me hop in I'm gonna stage the
intervention all right so so the cycle
the stimulant depressant cycle is is a
whole mess I've been a active
participant on that field before
but if I could just return to some of
the questions that kicked us off
so why
why allow
or endorse the idea of a cup of coffee
in the morning number one right if if it
is after this Litany of of sins
and then how could coffee be associated
with any of the health benefits of sleep
and if so how is that the case
you're absolutely right I think you know
the time when I was writing the book a
few years ago the evidence was starting
to emerge there that
drinking coffee had health benefits and
there's been some great meta-analyzes
quite recently and it is striking and
you just can't really deny it on the
strength of the evidence that drinking
coffee is associated with numerous
health benefits and the reduction in
risk for numerous health conditions and
what's striking as you mentioned
elegantly is that many of the same
health related conditions that drinking
coffee
is associated with reducing are the very
same
diseases that sleep will also reduce in
terms of your risk so how on Earth does
this work they seem completely
paradoxical
the answer is antioxidants
because it turns out that the Coffee
Bean itself contains much more than just
caffeine it contains a very healthy dose
of antioxidants
a family called the polyphenols perhaps
the principal one is
well there's a number of different
polyphenols that it contains
but chlorogenic acids are probably the
the principal kind that we think carry
to an ester that carries some of these
health benefits so what we realized is
that the Coffee Bean because most people
in developed nations are still deficient
in their whole food dietary intake The
Humble Coffee Bean has been asked to
carry the Herculean weight of all of our
antioxidant needs and that's why
drinking coffee has is such a strong
statistical Health signal in the data
when you do epidemiological studies so
it's not the caffeine that's related to
the health benefits it's the
antioxidants and case in point if you
look at decaffeinated coffee you get
many of the same I was just going to say
I hate to spoil the party with a
question
if I could jump in for a second just a
quick side note so the
antioxidants and nutritional value of
coffee being in let's just say
less industrialized or lower income
strata of various countries is true also
for Coca in the Peruvian Andes and
elsewhere it's actually a source of
very important nutrition for for a lot
of these communities and Indigenous
groups so I just wanted to say that as
an aside also chlorogenic acid I think
is contained in other
quite a few other compounds and and
beverages if I'm not mistaken so I I
want to say that it's
present in yerba mate which they drink
all the time in Argentina I may be
getting that wrong so somebody can fact
check me but is chlorogenic acid found
in like Camellia sinensis tea plants or
or other types of of beverages or is it
particularly prevalent in coffee
no you can find it it's certainly
nowhere near exclusive to the Coffee
Bean itself yeah by the way it doesn't
have contain any chloride please don't
be worried about it you're drinking in
you know bleach or something like that
it's got nothing to do with that but yet
the chlorogenic acids that's certainly
one group it's not to say it's the only
group though there are others
acromide is another one that we've been
very interested in in terms of the
Coffee Bean which is another antioxidant
so it's a cluster of different
antioxidants that provide these benefits
any Brewing methods roasts grinds any
combination of those variables that if
one wanted to maximize for the good
stuff and minimize the
the the potential damage to sleep and
sleep architecture
any thoughts on on what that Goldilocks
combination might look like
it is interesting and by the way I think
the Goldilocks combination comes on to
the idea that you know when it comes to
coffee it's the dose and the timing that
make the poison here yeah that you know
obviously if you look at the health
benefits too once you get past about two
and a half three cups of coffee a day
the health benefits start to go down in
the opposite direction so it's not a
linear relationship don't start drinking
like seven cups of coffee and be mindful
of the timing but to come to your
question
I suppose if we're talking about
caffeine concentration and then maybe
antioxidant concentration
actually here I am going to do a feature
today I'm going to do a two by three
because you can think about the rows of
the this table being the caffeine and
the antioxidants and then the columns
three columns would be the roast maybe
of the Coffee Bean the grind of the
coffee being the granularity the
coarseness and then maybe the Brewing
method
it's not quite as simple as this but
certainly what we found is that for the
roast of the Coffee Bean and this comes
onto the color of the coffee bean a
coffee bean is a coffee bean in terms of
its
when it comes out what changes its color
is is how you roast it and what we found
is that
sort of gram for gram light roast
actually has about the same caffeine
content as dark roast but the issue is
that the dark roast the longer that you
roast it the more degraded The Coffee
Bean becomes and hence the lighter its
density so net net on average a lighter
roast will contain more caffeine than a
darker roast so it's a it's a little bit
complex in terms of the grind I think
it's fairly clear that fine grain coffee
produces a higher degree of caffeine
concentration than a coarse grain
now of course we're not talking about
Brewing methods yet but that's simply
probably on the basis of surface area
that the finer the grain the greater the
surface area the greater the release of
the caffeine
Brewing method is it's really
interesting if you look at some of the
data the longer the Brewing method the
greater the caffeine concentration
relative to shorter
also cold Brews tend to produce a
stronger caffeine content than hot Brews
I think part of that simply is down to
the duration of the Brew itself cold
Brews typically take longer and
therefore you you get a stronger pound
for the punch in terms of caffeine
so that's caffeine antioxidants
in terms of the chlorogenic acids
you're you're probably going to favor
lighter rather than darker roasts
lighter roasts typically have higher
amounts of chlorogenic acid
than darker roasts although
there is some evidence that dog roasts
have higher amounts of some of the other
antioxidants like
acromide for example you don't need to
worry too much in terms of the
antioxidants and also by the way
thankfully the decaffeinating process
still preserves the antioxidants and
that's why it's still related to the
health benefits you don't lose out on
the antioxidants when you switch to
decaffeinated
finer grains typically produce more
antioxidants than also grind
in terms of that and then Brewing method
it's probably that cold brew seems to
produce stronger antioxidant
concentrations than probably the next
down would be espresso preparation then
instantly instant
coffee seems to have finally higher
concentrations of antioxidants than drip
or sort of infusion bag versions so I'm
sure that I'll stand corrected by the
internet but that's sort of my reading
perfect